GREAT SHOW, TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE HAVE A BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE BEGIN OUR HANNITY WATCH ON
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR RADICAL
AGENDA FOR AMERICA.
NANCY PELOSI HAS NOW OFFICIALLY
TAKEN BACK THE GAVEL AND THE
HATE TRUMP DEMOCRATS ARE GEARING
UP TO CARRY OUT THE AGENDA THEY
WERE HIDING ALL DURING THE
ELECTION AND WE WERE WARNING YOU
ABOUT.
THEY WANT THEIR CRUMBS BACK.
THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE I.C.E.,
OPEN BORDERS, OBAMACARE ON
STEROIDS.
THEY WANT A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM,
ENDLESS, ENDLESS, ENDLESS
INVESTIGATIONS.
HOW DOES THAT HELP YOU?
THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE THE
PRESIDENT AND IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT?
THEY WOULDN'T TELL YOU.
HERE IT IS DAY ONE OF THE NEW
CONGRESS.
A DEMOCRAT REPRESENTATIVE HAS
ALREADY INTRODUCED ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
THEY NEED TO READ THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT WOULD BE A NICE INTELLECTUAL
EXERCISE FOR THEM.
THE NEWLY CROWNED SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI, SHE IS
REFUSING TO RULE OUT A PLAN TO
IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> MANY DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
YOU HAVE SAID IT WOULD BE SAD
AND DIVISIVE FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> IT WOULD BE.
>> TO PURSUE IMPEACH.
.
ARE YOU WILLING TO RULE IT OUT?
>> WE HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE MUELLER REPORT.
WE SHOULDN'T BE IMPEACHING FOR A
POLITICAL REASON AND WE
SHOULDN'T AVOID IMPEACHMENT FOR
A POLITICAL REASON.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT COMES
OUT.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL SHOULD HONOR AND OBSERVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
GUIDANCE THAT STATES A SITTING
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED?
>> I DO NOT THINK THAT IS
CONCLUSIVE, NO, I DO NOT.
>> SO YOU THINK IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER
COULD LEGALLY INDICT A SITTING
PRESIDENT?
>> LET'S JUST SEE WHAT MUELLER
DOES.
LET'S SPEND OUR TIME ON GETTING
RESULTS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> AS YOU WELL KNOW, THERE IS
LONG STANDING DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE GUIDANCE THAT STATES A
SITTING PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT BE
INDICTED.
IT IS NOT THE LAW.
>> IT IS NOT THE LAW.
EVERYTHING INDICATES THAT A
PRESIDENT CAN BE INDICTED AFTER
HE IS NO LONGER PRESIDENT.
>> AFTER HE IS NO LONGER
PRESIDENT.
OH, OKAY.
ALL THESE THINGS THESE TRUMP
HATERS WOULDN'T TELL YOU DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, NOW THEY ARE
REVEALING IT.
WE WERE RIGHT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IN ADDITION TO IMPEACHMENT,
DEMOCRATS ARE PREPARING NEW
LEGISLATION THAT DEMANDS TEN
YEARS OF THE PRESIDENT'S TAX
RETURNS.
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR YOUR
LIFE.
YOU BETTER BELIEVE THEY PLAN FOR
A BIG TAX CUT.
NECESSARY PROBABLY ALL IMMINENT.
THERE ARE NO MODERATES LEFT IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SCOOP
JACKSON, MORE CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO GET
THINGS DONE, COMING TOGETHER,
BIPARTISANSHIP, I DON'T SEE IT.
AS IT GETS PUSHED FURTHER AND
FURTHER TO THE EXTREME RADICAL
LEFT, WE HAVE INCOMING
SOCIALIST, ALEXANDRIA OCASIO
CORTEZ AND RASHIDA TALEB.
THEY ARE JOINING THEIR FELLOW
COMRADE, BERNIE SANDERS, IN
CONGRESS.
SINGLE PAYER, MEDICAID FOR ALL,
GOVERNMENT-FUNDED HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR ALL, A GREEN NEW
DEAL WITH MASSIVE GOVERNMENT
FUNDING FOR, QUOTE, RENEWABLE
CLEAN ENERGY.
DIDN'T WE TRY THAT?
THEY ARE NOT JUST COMING FOR
YOUR CRUMBS.
THEY WANT THE ENTIRE MEAL.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED.
THAT'S THE BIG NEWS TONIGHT.
THIS IS ALL ONE BIG SHOW.
NO BILL IS GOING TO PASS WITHOUT
THE APPROVAL OF THE REPUBLICAN
SENATE OR THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT.
THANKS TO THE PRESIDENT'S HARD
WORK FOR THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS,
REPUBLICANS PICKED UP SEATS IN
THE SENATE AND THEY HAVE A SOLID
MAJORITY.
LET ME MAKE A PREDICTION, THEY
WILL NEVER, EVER, EVER, IN SPITE
OF ALL THEIR HOPES AND PRAYERS
AND DREAMS AND THEIR GIDDYNESS
AND THEIR EXCITEMENT AND THE
HATE TRUMP MEDIA SAYING IT, THEY
ARE NEVER GOING TO GET
TWO-THIRDS OF THE U.S. SENATE TO
VOTE TO CONVICT TRUMP ON
IMPEACHMENT.
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY ARE WASTING AMERICA'S TIME
AND THEY ARE STOPPING PROGRESS.
STILL, NONE OF THIS IS STOPPING
HOUSE DEMOCRATS FROM PROMOTING A
SPENDING BILL THAT REFUSES TO
FUND ANY PART OF A WALL ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ZERO DOLLARS.
THEY WERE OFFERING $1.6 BILLION.
NOW, IT IS ZERO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HOLDING THE
LINE.
HE IS DEMANDING DEMOCRATS.
WHY?
THEY DON'T WANT A BARRIER.
WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT AND WHY
DO THEY SUPPORT IT, JUST FOUR
SHORT YEARS AGO, THEY WERE ALL
SOUNDING LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU CAN CALL IT A BARRIER.
YOU CAN CALL IT WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
ESSENTIALLY, WE NEED PROTECTION
IN OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE IT GOOD.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY WANT
IT.
I HAVE NEVER HAD SO MUCH SUPPORT
AS I HAVE IN THE LAST WEEK OVER
MY STANCE FOR BORDER SECURITY,
FOR BORDER CONTROL, AND FOR
FRANKLY THE WALL OR THE BARRIER.
WITHOUT A WALL, YOU CANNOT HAVE
BORDER SECURITY.
WITHOUT A VERY STRONG FORM OF
BARRIER, CALL IT WHAT YOU WILL.
WITHOUT A WALL, YOU CANNOT HAVE
BORDER SECURITY.
IT WON'T WORK.
DO YOU SEE WHAT'S JUST BEEN PUT
OUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA WHERE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE RUSHING
THE BORDER.
HAVING A DRONE FLY OVERHEAD, AND
I THINK NOBODY KNOWS MUCH MORE
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY, THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY CERTAINLY THAN I DO.
HAVING DRONES AND VARIOUS OTHER
FORM OF CENSORS, THEY ARE ALL
FINE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP THE
PROBLEMS THAT THIS COUNTRY HAS.
WE'VE NEVER HAD MORE PEOPLE
WANTING TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE ECONOMY.
IT HAS TO DO WITH A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
WE ARE DOING GREAT AS A COUNTRY.
THE BETTER WE DO, THE MORE
PEOPLE WANT TO COME IN.
>> Sean: HERE IS THE TRUTH WE
ALL NEED TO KNOW.
THIS IS MUCH MORE THAN POLITICS.
IT IS ALL ABOUT POLITICS.
IT IS ALSO A MATTER OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THE WALL IS JUST NOT SOME
HALLOWED CAMPAIGN TACTIC.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT OUR OWN
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE CALLING
FOR, THAT THEY DESPERATELY SAY
THEY WANT AND NEED.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT.
TAKE A STEP BACK AND LISTEN TO
THEM.
THEY ARE ON THE FRONT LINES.
>> I'VE BEEN A BORDER PATROL
AGENT FOR 21 YEARS.
I CAN PERSONALLY TELL YOU FROM
THE WORK THAT I HAVE DONE ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER THAT PHYSICAL
BARRIERS, THAT WALLS ACTUALLY
WORK.
YOU HEAR A LOT OF TALK FROM THE
EXPERT -- YOU HEAR A LOT OF TALK
THAT THERE ARE EXPERTS THAT SAY
THAT WALLS DON'T WORK.
I PROMISE YOU, IF YOU INTERVIEW
BORDER PATROL AGENTS, THEY WILL
TELL YOU THAT WALLS WORK.
>> WE ARE ALL AFFECTED BY THIS
SHUTDOWN.
WE HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME.
HOWEVER, IT COMES DOWN TO BORDER
SECURITY.
WE ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT WHAT HE IS DOING TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR NATION'S BORDERS, TO
TAKE CARE OF THE FUTURE OF THIS
UNITED STATES.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICAL PARTIES.
YOU ALL HAVE GOT TO ASK YOURSELF
THIS QUESTION, IF I COME TO YOUR
HOME, DO YOU WANT ME TO KNOCK ON
THE FRONT DOOR OR DO YOU WANT ME
TO CLIMB THROUGH THAT WINDOW?
>> I JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE CRIMINALS THAT
BORDER PATROL AGENTS APPREHEND
ON A DALEY BASIS, MURDERERS,
RAPISTS.
PEOPLE THAT COMMIT SERIOUS
CRIMES.
I.C.E. HAS BEEN DOING A GREAT
JOB IN DEPORTING THE PEOPLE BACK
TO THEIR COUNTRIES.
ONCE WE DEPORT THESE PEOPLE,
THESE CRIMINAL ALIENS WILL NOT
STAY IN THEIR COUNTRIES.
THEY HAVE BEEN DEPORTED AND THEY
WILL COME RIGHT BACK INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER, IF WE HAD A PHYSICAL
BARRIER, IF WE HAD A WALL, WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO STOP THAT.
>> Sean: I HAVE BEEN DOWN TO THE
BORDER 13 TIMES FROM THE RIO
GRAND TO SAN DIEGO.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE DRUG
WAREHOUSES, HELICOPTER,
ALL-TERRAIN VEHICLE, HORSEBACK.
YOU CAN LAUGH BUT I WAS.
BOATS, ON FOOT.
I HAVE WATCHED GANG MEMBERS
ARRESTED.
WE HAVE THE VIDEO.
ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
LISTEN TO THE AGENTS?
ARE THEY GOING TO PUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST?
HOW MANY AMERICANS NEED TO DIE
BECAUSE WE HAVE OPEN BORDERS AND
SANCTUARY CITY AND STATE
POLICIES BEFORE DEMOCRATS TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY?
HOW LONG ARE WE GOING TO WITNESS
DRUG TRAFFICKING TARGETING OUR
KIDS IN SMALL TOWNS AND BIG
CITIES OR THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OR THE INFILTRATION OF GANGS AND
EVEN TERRORISTS THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED TRYING TO CROSS OUR
BORDER ILLEGALLY AND GET INTO
THIS COUNTRY AND CAUSE US HARM
BEFORE THE DEMOCRATS STOP
PLAYING POLITICS?
FOUR YEARS AGO, THEY SUPPORTED
THE TRUMP POLICY.
HOW MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
MUST YOU, THE AMERICAN TAXPAY ER
MUST YOU, THE AMERICAN TAXPAY  R
MUST YOU, THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER
SPEND IN DEPORTATION FEES, COURT
COSTS, HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION,
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM,
OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES BEFORE WE
START CONTROLLING IMMIGRATION AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
I HAVE SAID THIS MANY, MANY
TIMES.
I AM CERTAIN, 98%, 99% OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO CROSS THE
BORDER INTO THIS COUNTRY, THEY
JUST WANT A BETTER LIFE.
THE THINGS WE TAKE FOR GRANTED,
FREEDOM, OPPORTUNITY, HOPE FOR
THEIR KIDS, THEIR GRANDKIDS.
WE JUST WANT TO DO IT LEGALLY,
VET THEM.
BIG WALL, BIG DOOR.
THAT'S WHY IN TONIGHT'S HANNITY
WATCH ON THE BORDER AND THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, WE ARE
CALLING B.S. ON ALL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS FAKE ATTEMPTS TO
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO LISTEN TO
THE BORDER PATROL.
THEY REFUSED TO LISTEN TO A
SECURITY BRIEFING YESTERDAY WITH
THE HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY,
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
THEY REFUSED TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE PRESIDENT OVER THE HOLIDAYS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP STAYED IN
WASHINGTON.
HE DIDN'T GO DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO
OVER CHRISTMAS HOPING THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND NEGOTIATE A
DEAL.
NANCY PELOSI WAS ON A LUXURIOUS
VACATION IN BEAUTIFUL HAWAII,
SOME 12 HOURS AWAY, SIX HOURS
BEHIND THE TIME IN D.C.
WHEN CONFRONTED BY NBC NEWS, SHE
SAID THIS ABOUT LEAVING TOWN FOR
VACATION.
>> NOW, YOU HAD SAID BEFORE THE
SHUTDOWN THAT HE WAS BEING QUITE
CAVALIER AND MAYBE THE SHUTDOWN
WOULD GIVE HIM MORE TIME TO
GOLF.
IN THE END, IT WAS YOU THAT TOOK
A HOLIDAY.
>> I OBSERVED THE CHRISTMAS
HOLIDAY FOR A FEW DAYS AND THAT
WAS HALF THE TIME I WOULD HAVE
HAD WITH MY FAMILY.
>> WAS THAT A CHEAP SHOT?
>> IT IS NOT IMPORTANT.
IT IS TOTALLY UNIMPORTANT.
THE PRESIDENT MAY NOT KNOW THIS
BUT HAWAII IS PART OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T REALIZE THAT.
>> Sean: OVER THIS PAST WEEKEND,
WE LOST A POLICE OFFICER.
HIS NAME WAS OFFICER SINGH.
THIS GUY WAS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SHERIFF OF THAT COUNTY WAS
ON THIS SHOW LAST NIGHT SAYING
THE SANCTUARY POLICIES PLAYED A
BIG PART IN WHAT HAPPENED,
BECAUSE THE MURDERER WAS
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND WAS NEVER DEPORTED.
SPEAKER PELOSI, THE PRESIDENT
WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE WAITING
TO NEGOTIATE, YOU WERE THOUSAND
OF MILES AWAY, LAPPING IT UP,
LIFE OF LUXURY, PLAYING POLITICS
WITH BORDER SECURITY.
AMERICANS DIED OVER THE COURSE
OF THAT WEEKEND.
AN AMERICAN HERO, POLICE
OFFICER, WITH A FIVE-MONTH-OLD
SON, IS NO LONGER ON THIS EARTH
PROVIT
PROVDT
PROVDE
PROVING FOR HIS CHILD.
THIS IS NOW DAY ONE OF THE
PELOSI SHUTDOWN.
SHE OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
DACA.
THE PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO
NEGOTIATE DACA AND WILLING TO
TALK ABOUT DREAMERS.
HE IS WILLING TO PUT THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST.
IS SHE NOW DOING -- WHAT SHE IS
NOW DOING, IS THIS IN AMERICA'S
BEST INTEREST, YOUR BEST
INTEREST, YOUR FAMILY'S BEST
INTEREST?
IT SEEMS LIKE PEOPLE ONLY CARE
ABOUT DESTROYING AND HATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND EVERYONE
AROUND HIM.
HATING TRUMP IS NOW THEIR
SINGULAR FOCUS OF EVERY SECOND,
OF EVERY MINUTE, OF EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY.
PELOSI IS NOT THE ONLY ADVERSARY
ON CAPITOL HILL.
ON WEDNESDAY, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN, HANK JOHNSON,
ACTUALLY COMPARED PRESIDENT
TRUMP, AND ALL OF HIS SUPPORTERS
TO NAZIS.
TODAY, SIRIUS XM PATRIOTS, KERRY
PICKET ASKED JOHNSON ABOUT THOSE
HATE-FILLED REMARKS AND HE
DOUBLES DOWN.
>> WHAT I DID WAS COMPARE THE
TIMES THAT WE LIVE IN TO THE
TIMES THAT EXISTED AT THE TIME
HITLER GAINED POWER.
I MENTIONED THE FACT THAT HE
GAINED POWER THROUGH DEMOCRATIC
ELECTIONS, THE SAME WAY TRUMP
DID, OUR RIGHT TO SPEAK, FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS, DUE PROCESS, EQUAL
PROTECTION OF THE LAW, ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE THREATENED BY
THE CURRENT CLIMATE OF RIGHT
WING EXTREMISM.
>> Sean: NOW, REMEMBER, THIS IS
THE SAME GENIUS CONGRESSMAN THAT
OPENLY WORRIED THAT THE ISLAND
OF GUAM WAS GOING TO CAPSIZE AND
TIP OVER IF TOO MANY U.S.
MILITARY PERSONNEL WERE
STATIONED ON THE ISLAND.
THEY WERE GOING TO TIP THE
ISLAND OVER.
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
THAT'S YOUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY NOW
IN CONTROL OF THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND, OF COURSE,
DEMOCRATS AREN'T THE ONLY PEOPLE
WORKING AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
EVEN INCOMING SENATOR, MITT
ROMNEY, HE WANTED TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT, NOW CRITICIZING
TRUMP IN AN OP ED CAUSING MANY
OF HIS REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO
RESOUNDLY SLAM THE FRESHMAN
SENATOR.
HE CAUGHT UP WITH ROMNEY TODAY
AND ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS ROUGH
START ON CAPITOL HILL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Reporter: THE PRESIDENT
ENDORSED YOU AND NOW YOU HAVE
MADE THIS OP ED.
HOW IS THAT NOT CONSIDERED A
STAB IN THE BACK?
>> IT IS CERTAINLY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THINGS WHERE WE
AGREE.
I SAID PRIOR TO THE PRIMARY IN
AN OP ED I WROTE IN THE UTAH
PAPERS, I WOULD WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON PLACES WE AGREE AND
WHERE WE DISAGREED, I WOULD
POINT THAT OUT.
THAT'S THE GREAT NATURE OF THIS
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
WHERE WE AGREE, WE COME
TOGETHER.
WHERE THERE ARE DISAGREEMENTS,
WE EXPRESS THOSE OPENLY AND
HONESTLY.
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO HAVE TRUST
IN ONE ANOTHER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVE A
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS DESPITE
DIFFERENCES FROM TIME TO TIME.
>> Sean: 2020 IS JUST AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
ROMNEY IS GOING TO NEED TO ASK
HIM, WHAT'S BETTER FOR THE
COUNTRY, THE PRESIDENT'
PROGROWTH AGENDA, LOWER TAXES
AND LESS REGULATION, WE ARE NOW
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE NOW MAKING MORE OIL THAN
SAUDI ARABIA AND RUSSIA.
WE ARE, FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
DECADES, ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
DOES HE WANT ORIGINAL SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES, BORDER SECURITY
OR THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA TO LIKE
HIM OR HATE TRUMP DEMOCRATS OR
THE HATE TRUMP DEEP STATE HELL
BENT ON DESTROYING THE NOT ONLY
THE PRESIDENT BUT A DUAL ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS ANNOUNCED
HER PRESIDENTIAL BID AFTER
SAYING SHE WASN'T GOING TO RUN
IN MARCH.
I THOUGHT DEMOCRATS HATE LYING
OR NOT REMEMBERING CORRECTLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HEAR THE PRESIDENT GOING
AFTER YOU FROM TIME TO TIME
REFERRING TO YOU AS POCAHONTAS.
DOES THAT GET UNDER YOUR SKIN
WHEN HE DOES THAT?
DO YOU WANT TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2020?
>> I AM NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2020.
>> I THOUGHT TRUMP HATERS DIDN'T
LIKELYIN
LIKE YIN
LIKE LYN
LIKE LYING.
THE PRESIDENT WASTED NO TIME FOR
CALLING HER OUT FOR HER
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS OF
NATIVE-AMERICAN HERITAGE MOCKING
HER INFAMOUS DNA TEST AND HER
LIFE OF LIES.
SOME ON THE LEFT ARE COMING
AFTER THE 2020 HOPEFUL OVER THE
DEPOC
DEBACLE.
IN THE "HUFFINGTON POST," HER
INSULT TO NATIVE AMERICANS
MATTERS MOST.
THEY SLAM HER FOR REFUSING TO
STOP SAYING HER FAMILY IS PART
NATIVE.
ANDREW CUOMO BEGINNING HIS THIRD
TERM USING HIS INAUGURAL ADDRESS
TO SLAM PRESIDENT TRUMP, OF
COURSE.
>> FROM VOTING REFORMS TO ROE V.
WADE FOR NEW YORK, TO PROTECTING
A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE, TO
BETTER GUN LAWS, TO HEALTH CARE
PROTECTION, TO LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA, TO PROTECTING THE
LABOR MOVEMENT, TO A GREEN NEW
DEAL, TO REAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, WE WILL MAKE HISTORY.
NEW YORK WILL MOVE FORWARD, NOT
BY BUILDING A WALL, MY FRIENDS
BUT BY BUILDING NEW BRIDGES AND
BUILDING NEW AIRPORTS AND
CREATING NEW MIDDLE CLASS JOBS.
>> Sean: MAYBE CUOMO SHOULD
SPEND MORE TIME FOCUSING ON HIS
OWN STATE, NOW HOME TO ONE OF
THE MOST CORRUPT AND INEFFICIENT
GOVERNMENTS IN THE COUNTRY WITH
NEW YORKERS LEAVING THE STATE IN
DROVES MOVING TO TAX HAVENS LIKE
TEXAS AND FLORIDA, A DISGRACE.
A LOT MORE THAN THAT.
TONIGHT'S HANNITY WATCH ON THE
DEEP STATE.
OUR OWN KATHERINE HERITAGE
REPORTING, HOUSE REPUBLICANS
SHUTTERING THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FACTIONS DURING THE
2016 CAMPAIGN AS THEY HAND OVER
POWER.
THEIR FINAL FINDINGS REVEAL FBI
DIVISIONS OVER THE CLINTON CASE
OVER ROD ROSENSTEIN'S COMMENTS
ABOUT RECORDING THE PRESIDENT.
CHAIRMAN DOUGHTY AND GOODLET
CALLED FOR A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE DECISIONS
MADE BY THE DOJ AND THE DISPA
DISPARITE WAY THESE
INVESTIGATIONS WERE CONDUCTED.
THEY WERE INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT AND TALKING ABOUT
REMOVING THE PRESIDENT THEY
DIDN'T WANT ELECTED IN THE FIRST